on today's show we talked to a woman
who's pregnant and she just found out
her husband cheated on her and gave her
an std
we also talked to a mom who's been
struggling with working from home and
homeschooling and her kids have had
enough we talked to a kind father
who's wondering how to tell his 12 year
old son that he was adopted many years
ago
stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what up what up this is delony with
the dr john deloney
show thanks for joining us today hope
you're doing well hope you're healthy
hope you're laughing a lot hope your
life's filled with joy
and if it's not i hope you've got
something
some plans today to turn that around
right
on this show we take your calls about
life we talk about your mental health we
talk about education we talk about
relation like you
family everything anything that's going
on in your heart in your mind
we take calls from all over the world
and i tell you what these emails are
coming in and they're coming in and
they're coming in
and i love it keep sending them if you
want to get on the show if you want to
join us for these conversations
um give me a call at 1-844-693-3291
that's
six nine three thirty two ninety one or
go
to johndaloni.com show fill out the form
it goes right to kelly
the associate producer of the show the
skull call
the skull creamer the call screener
extraordinaire
she's a ninja she's one of the og ninjas
and she will see if we can get you on
the show so every time
we start the show we either have some
positive news some negative news
things that drive me crazy about the
world things that are just going on in
the world
and i think it's time that we just
waiting on james
yeah i got one um so so let me preface
this james said uh
hey i want to take this slot today yeah
it's a little bit of an intervention
annoying thing you you keep doing this
like horse noise
on the show and i think you did it the
last show like
27 times approximately it's the
i don't do that no not that it's the
so i do that a lot you do we have to
clean up the desk
all the spit off the desk afterwards
it's kind of a gross code it sounds
c1 yeah so that's annoying try to stop
doing that
so give me an example of when i do that
um
anytime all the time idiot
whatever yeah whenever you get when you
get stumped or perplexed about a call
let's clear this up i never get stun i
get stomped every show
and then i go nay so you're going to do
it today and then you're going to
realize it
or i'll point at you and then you'll
realize it and it's okay you're never
going to unhear it now
i'm never going to unhear it there's a
lot of things i can on here
okay so when i do that noise today
you've got to just stop
intervene no matter what's going on and
be like hold on you did it again
i get it i just think that the level of
animal noises you make should be
disproportionate to the amount of
doctorate degrees you have and so
as with the diarrhea jokes that too so
hey just work on it enough
fix it all right everybody there you go
america and earth
the producer is producing the animal
noises out of this show that i didn't
even know i was making
i'm gonna start oinking or something
weird i wish turtles made noises i'd
make that noise
man that's what feedback sounds like
good folks hey i wanna i wanna
be a personality i wanna have a podcast
i'd love to work with a great team
and then they they take your ticks and
the things you don't even know you do
and they're like um that's embarrassing
and weird please shut up and stop doing
that
it's annoying but you know there's some
people out there that are gonna be like
no i love when he does that
there will they're gonna send you hate
mail be like oh first unity and now
horse noises james what are you taking
from us
and then there's gonna be others that
are just gonna send you gift cards be
like thanks man
podcast is okay but he kept sounding
like a horse he's an idiot all right
we're done with horse noises
i was gonna make one more but i'm not
even going to all right let's go to the
phones
i don't even know where to start you
screwed up my mojo man all right let's
go to samantha in
austin texas what's up samantha how are
you
doing
uh hi dr john how are you doing i'm
doing all right how's the 512
uh it's really cold it's really cold i
don't think i've ever heard those words
before that's pretty cool
oh got like record low temperatures here
it's crazy
very cool very cool all right so what's
going on how can i help
um well i am six months pregnant
with my third child and um
how old are the other ones uh i have a
two and a half year old and a one year
old
oh my two
and a half and one and a six month in
the oven
yeah i would just like on behalf of
humanity to
say god bless you i don't even i don't
even know what to say after that other
than
okay go forward go ahead
got our hands full yes well my
husband came to me recently and he
told me that he was with someone else
and um that he
probably contracted an std and that i
most likely have it as well
and so i've gone and been tested and
that is
the case um
yeah you're confirmed holy crap i'm so
sorry
that sucks
what's the what's the sti uh it's uh
chlamydia so it's something that's um
treatable
thankfully i'm so sorry so have you gone
to your
ob gyn to talk through any implications
with your pregnancy
um yeah and i have walk me through that
um basically i'll just do the treatment
and um
it should clear up and we just have to
do some follow-up and
just to make sure that everything is um
normal and healthy and then it should
not
it'll be like it never happened oh man
i'm so sorry
yeah but it did happen right yeah yeah
so i'm going to ask you to do something
weird as we talk through this okay
i want to take the sti part and i want
to set that off to the side for a second
okay and i want to take the
overjoyed exhausted i haven't slept in
what four years now when you add in all
the
pregnancies completely exhausted
at a psychological and spiritual and
physical level right
and then to get this news because what i
don't want to do
as we as we walk through this i don't
want that
um the consequence of what happened to
be the focus just yet i don't want to
get back to
this conversation y'all had tell me how
the conversation went
um basically he just came and he told me
like this happened
and now um like i'm
having symptoms and it was just kind of
all just very surreal
um i i didn't see it coming at all
okay total total shock to you oh yeah i
mean
i would have never guessed in a million
years that
he would have done something like that
and so
how can i help there's so much here how
can i help
i mean it just my
i know my family is like well like
obviously like you just you leave
and like of course and you know they're
like and i mean
that's not necessarily like
the thing that i mean i want i have i
mean
i came from a very broken family and i
didn't want my kids to be raised in that
i didn't want them to
ever feel that and um so now i've just
got
a very big decision of where i go from
here yeah
what do you want to do forget with your
parents and your family and all the
people
telling you what you're going to tell
you you're going to have people that
will sit you down and buy you a cup of
coffee
and look you in the eye and say i know
this is heartbreaking but
you and your husband have a future
together you're gonna get through this
if y'all both want to and you can do the
hard work and then you're gonna have
somebody call you and be like
oh you're just gonna be a cuckold for
the rest of your life you're just gonna
let him do
you know i mean so forget all those
voices
and also forget the and it's gonna sound
ridiculous
forget the um
fantasy that you had about i want my
kids to have this because i had
another picture right i had another
experience in my life so i painted this
picture that's gonna happen no matter
what
because that might force that might
encourage you to drag yourself through
mud that you don't need to go through
right um
what do you want to do put all those
things down and just talk to me
directly what do you want to do
um i mean i i do want
to work things out like you know i still
love him and i
he said it was a one-time thing and i i
genuinely believed that it was
have you ever gone to see anybody um
no i've got some it's coming up
scheduled
okay is he when you say
um he told you as a one-time thing and
he came to you with this is he still all
in is he
say i screwed up i'm so sorry i'm going
to make this right here's all my phones
here's all my computer stuff i want you
to know
i am i am this is this is an accident
happened and i'm going to do anything it
takes to
repair this and not even repair it or
rebuild you got to rebuild something new
now right
um what's his heart and space on this
i mean he's just i mean apologizing
to me about like 5 000 million times a
day
and he called a marriage counselor and
just
tried to get everything hooked up and
he's
he's he's trying and he's you know like
you can track me here's all my passwords
here's all my everything
and um
so you believe him
as much as you can right i mean after
it's like you've had
like the the deepest violation hurt
right and so
i know that sounds trite be like all
right cool you're ready to get back on
that horse and ride again i get that
um but your gut tells you
but i i genuinely just i mean i hope i
mean you know i
in my gut i feel like it really was just
a
single incident okay so here's the thing
you owe nobody an explanation for
choosing to stay with them
you owe nobody an explanation for
choosing to
give it a shot to try and
when you have this third baby and
when you have some time to actually
grieve and when you have time to process
this and to like let the um you know the
the fight or flight response right that
shock wear off and you actually can look
in the eye and say
dude you could have hurt us both bad
because you violated us
and you were stupid when you did it um
and you choose you know what i gave it
six months i'm out i gave it
you know 10 months and i can't you don't
owe anybody an explanation then
and if you choose to bail tomorrow you
don't owe anybody an explanation for
that
okay i want you to feel free from that
and everybody's gonna have an opinion
remember when you first got pregnant the
first time how many
stupid advice droplet droplets that
sounds like a sneeze but it's basically
what it is it's just snot
everyone's stopping like okay make sure
you've got somebody to text and make
sure this and you should use this
remember those days oh yeah that's
what's coming
except 10 times worse because everyone
feels on moral high ground on this one
so they're all gonna give you their
girl you know it's all it's common dude
so um
i mean i always thought it would be a
no-brainer for me and i would just
like that obviously come out like yeah
you just
would just of course you leave but and i
was just i was just talking to somebody
recently and they said the opposite they
were like i just
knew that if that ever happened we'd
work through it and we'd move on
and then they said it happened and it's
like i'm out like i
just knew in my guts that was that that
was that right so
here's a couple of things i'll recommend
number one is
um you've got to have somebody privately
that you can grieve this with
okay um i can hear it in you
like this is an existential thing this
is a thing you swore would never happen
this is a thing you've probably
leaned really hard into making sure that
your family stayed together
this is a a what i call like a grave
soul injury
and not in a overly spiritual kind of
way but this is something that rocks
people to their absolute core okay so
yes you need to go to marriage
counseling y'all gotta work on that
immediately but you need somebody that
you can talk to privately as well okay
the second thing is this you can't
recreate what was now
you've got to build something completely
new
the language that they use that i love
the metaphor that
i use all the time is this
when the twin towers fell down they
couldn't sweep up all that glass
and steel and metal and
tape it and glue it all back together
and recreate those towers they had to
excavate the whole site throw that stuff
in the dump
and build something completely new and
what they built new is beautiful and
stunning and extraordinary and strong
and will last for hundreds of years but
you had to
do the hard work of getting architecture
designs and engineering and redo the
whole thing
okay and so you're on a journey now to
build something completely new
and what i see happens with couples a
lot when they're trying to recover from
some sort of violation like this is they
try to get what was back and that you
can't
and so you end up feeling like you're
failing instead of saying okay that's
over
we are now starting again and we're
gonna have to rebuild something
completely new
and i know that's exhausting and hard
not the thing you want to do with three
kids under three right
um yeah and then the other thing man is
you're gonna have to have to have to and
this is gonna sound like i'm flipping
sides here please hear my heart on this
okay if you are making a go of it
you got to choose grace and not to
weaponize everything around
around you around your husband around
your ecosystem okay
because at the end of the day you're
gonna just poison yourself hoping he
dies
and that's not gonna be how that works
okay
okay i'm heartbroken for you um
so i just gave you some things that like
here's what it's gonna look like to
rebuild
and you're talking years okay you're
talking months and years this is a big
deal
not to mention the consequence of it all
are you in
you're pretty awesome samantha
you're pretty awesome i know this sucks
and i know this hurts
i'm so so sorry for you
call somebody today somebody that's not
going to give you advice it's not going
to overwhelm you with
well you know what you should so i'm
just going to be with you and listen and
if that's a professional great
if you got that friend great
i'm so sorry i wish i could end this
call on a positive note everybody go get
them
rocks you know rock and roll and
fireworks
but this just sucks folks remember man
your actions
my dad used to say it's like throwing a
brick throwing a rock
in the lake and those ripple effects
you know they end up on shores way far
away you threw that rock right over
there man but it ends up
affecting the shoreline way across the
other side
and i know being married with young kids
is really hard
and i know being married young kids is
lonely i know being
i mean i can't even imagine i can't wrap
my head around three kids under the age
of three
um that's disney world in a circus in a
really small space
but man stay true
don't cheat stay true stay true man
don't cheat stay true
all right let's go to uh leanne in san
francisco
leanne what's going on yes sir dr john
thanks for taking my call how are you
i'm so so good how are you
well blessed and highly favored very
cool
very cool how's san francisco today
beautiful
sun's out but rain's coming tomorrow so
we're trying to
soak it in the day very cool what's up
what's up how can i help
all right all right so i'm a mom working
mom full time
uh three kids but two are school aged
my 11 year old son
is having an especially difficult time
yeah we're not going to back to school
anytime soon
so my boy normally happy-go-lucky
kid very creative hilarious but
we're where he's having a tough time
he's trying to run away a couple times
two times he's tried to run away to get
away from it all is
how he put it and um he's
he's made mention of suicide so
my question is when do i say
that's it i need to seek the help of a
professional
um the second you get off this phone
call
okay okay
this work from home this school from
home for kids
is um this is going to be a generational
trauma that we don't fully understand
for years and years and years and years
and years
it's devastating kids are so hyper
co-regulated
that's just nerd speak for their hearts
beat and their eyes widen and their
faces move
based on the heartbeats and eye movement
and face movements and body movements of
other people in their area it's how they
interact with space it's how they
interact with themselves it's how their
brain regulates itself
through other people and this has been
an absolute physiological and
psychological nightmare for them
and you throw on top of that mom the my
safe space
is being forced to have a dual role
right and i don't know that side of mom
i don't know work
mom i don't know teacher mom and you're
being forced into roles that you didn't
sign up for and you you're not equipped
to do right but then you feel guilty
because i'm mom i'm supposed to be able
to care for my son and then all of a
sudden you know what i mean it just
turns into a mess and i'm so
so sorry leanne i hate that for you and
i hate that for your family hit that for
every kid in the country
um anytime um
a kid mentioned suicide it stopped the
presses
we're seeing i read an article recently
um
talked about on the show um whereas
a kid as young as nine took his life in
in las vegas
and we're seeing suicide rates among
children really ratchet up they're just
so
so so lonely and they're losing those
safe spaces which has been home
and they're losing those what i call
accidental community where you just that
teacher winks at you in the hallway
or pat you on the shoulder they're
missing all that stuff and their bodies
are just in their hearts and minds are
going haywire
tell me what it's like homeschooling
your kid kid that you love a little boy
that you love
man it's i mean i'm i'm barely hanging
on myself like
literally by the skin of my teeth just
and then you go to bed and got to do it
again the next day
um welcome walk me through what a day's
like
so i get up i try to get up at 5 a.m so
i get a little bit of
un disturbed work time on my computer i
work at a hot
i'm at hospital administration so it's
you know crazy at work as well i was
gonna say yeah that's a barrel of roses
this year too right
right oh right you're in california too
just exactly
one barrel of monkeys after another
right and i want to be a good team
member help my you know the clinical
folks
that are really putting the work in as
well so um
so get them up about so he likes to get
up early so he can also prepare for the
day and um
then we jump right on the computers and
i'm bouncing between my two kids
and my my work and um
it's it's chaos and then the grind
after they get off the computers to get
the
work done because it's not just in class
work it's
once they get off you have this laundry
list of assignments that have to get
done
by a certain hour you know nonsense
the pedagogy there is garbage school
administrators across the country i'm
calling you out it's trash dude
it's ridiculous because here's what's
happening and i'm not mad at you i'm so
frustrated with how some of these
schools are handling this
they are getting these reports of
learning decreases
and instead of doing what the science
says which is get these kids off these
screens and let them go walk around the
neighborhood and let them go play let
them go wrestle
they're doubling down on the other side
well after you get off you got to do
more
problems and more math and more this
and we're embedding in these kids not
only this just
failure factory this disaster factory
but we're also embedding in these kids
a distaste for learning and it's just a
gross mess i'm so sorry that i'm you
you're pushing my buttons here i'm half
the country away from me
no don't be sorry it's man um
and so then your kids get done with
their homework and then what you're back
in it
now you have to toggle back to mom and
after a frustrating exhausting day
yeah quite then i turn this shuttle mom
because i'm trying to keep them active
thank god there's my daughter is doing
gymnastics i have him in an exercise
class because i just need them to move
their bodies
good for you and um you know when he
first tried to run
run away i called it i said screw it i
called his buddy's mom i said
can chris play because i need to get my
kid out of the house
we're gonna risk our physical health
for his mental health so he has some
buddies in the neighborhood that he'll
ride bikes with etc
hey that is that is mom of the year
right now good for you
good for you good for you
and i know that's a risk i know that's a
risk and get my show canceled all that
stuff i don't care
no i'm good for you like there's a lot
of parents that are just
just you gotta draw the line somewhere i
mean
the kids are going crazy yeah so
um i won't i won't divulge too much um
my wife and i are still negotiating not
really negotiating we're still working
through
um which parts of my family life i
disclose
for all these people on the show and
which parts that i keep to myself
what i will tell you is um
i have heard the heartbreak firsthand
that you just expressed okay
and here's what i want to not we haven't
experienced the mental health challenges
and suicide challenges
but i have i've got a memory in my heart
that will be there forever
with an encounter of my son and
and weeping in a way that i've never
seen him weep before
and um just saying dad when is this
going to
and listening to him and my
wife and my daughter negotiate
homeschooling and homework from home and
all those things
so here's what i want to give you
permission to do
at some point your roi on your work
world begins to diminish
because home world is hard right and not
only hard but it's
taking your core out from under you
right
um the core of who you are which is an
extraordinary mom are
you married you got somebody else there
helping out or is it just you my husband
um he has to go in so he's um
he's home till about 10 o'clock and then
we don't see him again for the rest of
night
okay um so that might even be a good
thing there
your kids i i want to see them have more
direct we'll get to school and get to
school
dad and the kids are going for a walk
dad and the kids are setting up a wwe
wrestling tournament in the living room
and we're just going for it for a while
we will get to the classroom assignments
when we get to them
and at some point um
you guys have to double down on that
parent connection
and even saying i'm going to be
homeschool mom
for this period of time and i'm going to
make you i want you to call me by
another name because i want to
have a moment when i can be your mommy
and right now i'm going to be your
teacher so call me miss jo
whatever dude but here's what i'm trying
to do set up some boundaries between
those roles because it's
really confusing for a kid and you as a
hospital administrator you are used to
toggling so fast between
all these different things all the time
right an 11 year old just sees mom
and sees mom working at a pace and
saying things to her clients and
to her co-workers like whoa i don't know
she talked like that i know
she knew what a tps report is and all
that stuff right
his mind's getting blown and his picture
of mom is morphing in front of him in a
way that his little 11 year old brain
can't comprehend right now
and you throw on that how frustrated you
are when he's like i don't get the word
problem you're like do the word brother
right
all of that and so set up some some
boundaries like that and they can be
silly
and fun like when i put on the big
yellow crown that him and
you know your other kid can cut and
paste and make a hat for you for teacher
hat
whatever but we're gonna set up some fun
silly things that are gonna
let them have some boundaries between
the roles and then
i don't i can't believe i'm saying these
things i
said it in a in a speech the other day
like get in front of the tv and just
hold your kids right yeah
like just turn the stupid screens on i
hate screens i'm pub i'm i'm
overly loud about how much i hate them
but at some point you just gotta hold
your kids
right and sit down and color with them
it's worth you know that's gonna heal
your heart it's gonna help heal their
heart
whatever that looks like we played zoom
pictionary a couple of nights ago with
my grand with their grandparents my
parents
and i got to say this shout out to my 70
year old mom
who had to act out quicksand via zoom
on a webcam it did not end
pretty and it was awesome though she
went all in and then my dad who's 70
he had got sumo wrestling as one of the
charade cards
and that image will never it burned a
hole in my rods and cones in my eyes
like in my retina
so all i have to say is figure out what
those weird crazy
fun things you can do and double down on
them but
let your kids know that you love and
cherish them and
at this point after a year of being home
man loving and cherishing letting those
kids know they've got value and letting
those kids know that they are still
tethered into you
is more important than whatever they're
going to pick up in social studies or
math class
at this point across the country it's so
uneven it's so
wonky some schools have never shut down
some schools have
not gone back it's just going to be such
unequal
mess that i'm way more concerned
about the the connection and the love
and the peace and these kids
hearts all the way back to your original
question
11 year old runs away because he's
frustrated man
i'm i'm not going to not every alarm is
going to go off there i'm going to talk
to my kid and make sure he knows he's
loved i'm going to go for a walk with
them those kind of things
um i'm gonna let him ride bikes in the
neighborhood with his kids
my kid says i'm thinking about not being
here everything in my world stops work
can wait till later
friendships can wait till later all that
stops i'm calling a professional right
now
and i'm gonna do my best my best best to
get an
in-person meeting with that person
because just going on another
zoom call for your poor kid um
hopefully that they would let you do
that i don't know what the rules are
there i know they are having some
in-person allowances here
um in tennessee here we'll be thinking
about you
and um man you're doing the right thing
set up those boundaries set up those um
those moments of high high touch high
high physical contact
high high let them cook dinner those
things where they get to contribute and
be a part of the family household
where they get to see you being silly
where they get to have work with mom for
a minute whatever those things are
let them feel a part of the home like
they've got value and let them ride
bikes with their friends man
and um geez louise i'm so so sorry
um yeah i'm sorry liam i wish i could
wrap this up and make it so great too
the second call in a row
that i want to just put a bow on this
one and it's hard because we're right in
the middle of a
massive massive trauma school
administrators
i know i know i'm being a jerk here man
because i know you too i've got close
friends all over the country school
administrators
pedagogically speaking you know this
eight hours for a ten-year-old in front
of a screen followed by three more hours
in front of a screen
is not learning stop
come up with something else and i know
you got to get your test scores i know
that i know there's funding on top of
those i know all those things
figure it out there's too much science
out there there's too much there's too
much
and i also want to be safe i'm not
saying everyone should go back to
schools y'all figure that out locally
i'm not getting in the middle of that
mess but i'm telling you pedagogically
speaking you know that these kids
cut off at a certain point stop piling
it on
stop piling it on these 11 year olds
he's 9 year olds he's 14 year olds he's
17 year olds
man let's let them remember this moment
not as the
as the the make or break moment when i
started hating learning
when i started hating learning let's
give them project basel i'm not going to
get into that dude
i'm going gonna make myself crazy all
right let's go to jonathan in pensacola
florida
i'm gonna sing my way to this next call
what's up jonathan how are you doing
doing good doctor dom how are you doing
i'm doing all right man so what's going
on brother
uh well first i just want to thank you
for taking my call a long time listener
since you started the podcast um yeah
thank you man i'm in a predicament um
so i have two kids a 12 year old boy and
a 10 year old girl
and the 12 year old boy is i adopted him
actually got with his mother when she
was a couple months pregnant actually
i've been there ever since i was there
for the birth i was there for
it all and um she recently passed away a
couple years ago
and uh i'm sorry man my life is my life
has moved on now and
i've met a great woman and
we actually come up pregnant a month so
ago
or a couple months ago and um wasn't
planned but you know how that goes
um
yeah i know how that goes i know that
all works
yeah but um i'm going to tell you
congratulations anyway
congratulations brother well thank you
john i'm i'm excited now for it it was
shocking but
i can't even wrap my head around what
that conversation would be like in my
house and my wife was like well
i gotta tell you something when you get
home yeah so man congratulations brother
thank you um well it's gonna be a boy
okay um and my wife's point is just
gonna be my first biological
boy and she don't want to
my son don't know that he's adopted yeah
and i heard the phone call the other
morning
of the the guy that found out he was
adopted and how it
affected him and i didn't know if i ever
planned on telling him in the
first place you know i i don't know i
just feel like i'm his dad you know it's
been there
um but my wife my wife thinks that
i shouldn't hide that from him and i
shouldn't hide it from
the new sign i just don't know how to go
about that doctor
i don't know how to he he's 12 i'm not a
i've already had to tell him that his
mom won't come off from the hospital
and now i got to tell him that you know
that i'm not his biological dad i just
don't know how to go about it
yeah so um number one man i appreciate
you
your heart on this deal you're yeah you
said it right you're in a predicament
um yeah first and foremost no secrets
man
no secrets ever um no secrets no secrets
no secrets
um they destroy families or a fire that
burns a family
to a crisp from the inside out it just
turns the whole thing to ash
the second thing is you're right on
man get rid of this biological language
you're about to have your second son
that is what it is with the purity into
that sentence
the moment you start saying well you're
that son
but this is my dude when you do that
you are creating chaos that you can
never you're creating trauma brother
that will burn through generations of
your family
and that's not your heart i know that
don't do that and
um you have to be pretty direct
with your new wife that there is not
going to be a that son
and this son right these boys
are going to be your boys your
daughter's going to be your daughter
these kids are gonna be y'all's kids and
that's gonna be that
everybody's gonna be treated equally and
loved and engaged and all that stuff
right um don't get that language even in
your head
okay so when it comes to telling your
son
i can't recommend enough that you
you've got to get with a professional at
this point that's going to walk you
through and there's
all kinds of ways to do that in very
gentle ways
there's just some some gentle ways that
a good
counselor and you're talking two or
three sessions this isn't a monumental
thing
and if he hasn't has he gone to
counseling for a trauma with his mom
lost
um you know i probably should have got
it done but
no i i haven't yet and i've i planned on
doing it
this year because my wife talked about
it at the end of last year
probably something i should have done
about the job but my life was kind of
chaotic at that point
hey there's no judgment here man we're
gonna we're gonna take tomorrow as a new
day and we're gonna go from there okay
and so here's what i want you to do i
want you to reach out to a
reputable um counselor who works with
kids in your area
let them know the situation that you
adopted this son from his birth with his
birth mom
and then she passed away a few years ago
he's 12
as he starts to hit puberty trauma is
the way i explain it is like taking a
bouncy ball and just humming it into a
kitchen
everybody can throw that bouncy ball and
it's going to bounce in a
million different directions but the
hormones the
the connection the desire to have deeper
relationship with friends
you know romantic relationships all that
stuff starts happening now
in a in a much more accelerated fashion
and so trauma is going to emerge in some
wonky ways
for him okay it's normal it's natural
you should expect it your new wife
should expect it
but you can start preempting some of
that now if you're not already seeing
i'd be surprised if you weren't already
seeing it but maybe you're not
and get with a counselor let them know
that you want to start
talking through some of those things and
that you want some guidance and
some support as you all begin to tell
them hey i'm not your biological dad
but i'm daddy i'm not your biological
father there's a better way to say that
but i'm your dad
i chose you of all the kids in the world
i chose you
i will always love you you're my oldest
son
we're about to have a new son and here's
an awesome way to um that
one of my professors dr marvel taught me
and it worked like a
champ man was when my wife got pregnant
with our
second she said start referring
to the second baby to the baby
in utero as their baby so you're gonna
start telling your son hey man when
you're
when your brother comes you're gonna
have a lot of responsibility
you and me we're gonna raise a good
young man here
we're gonna we're gonna really help him
be compassionate and empathetic and kind
we're gonna we're man me and you man
your brother your brother
and he's gonna take ownership and he's
gonna be excited and he's gonna have a
participation role and um own this big
brother stuff instead of seeing it as a
intrusion right someone who's taken
something from me right well i heard i
heard you talk about that a couple
episodes ago and that's the first thing
i did when we found out
yeah look at you man is your brother
and yeah like that and i want to say
that
my wife wasn't what like i don't want
her to seem like she's
a bad guy mr nothing she she wasn't
going to say
you know this is your sign this is your
biological
she was just she works in social work
and she's just
trying i guess try to point me in the
right direction that she might not know
everything
oh sure man and hey no i appreciate you
standing up for your wife man you're a
good guy
but i'm not trying to bad mouth your
wife but i do want everyone to be
cognizant
of is everything becomes different when
you hold
um in in a blended family like this
that kid that new kid that comes along
usually it's two or three or five in
your case
i don't know 12 or 13 years later right
that new kid
can have a a bonding effect can be
the shiny new toy leaving these new
teenagers who desperately desperately
need their parents attention feeling
like
they're outside the loop and it can be
really easy for
a new couple who gets together to want
to really super bond over this new baby
that we share together
and then the older kids can feel that
right so it's not drinking the hatred or
anything just something to be cognizant
of to think through
and you got a good wife man there are
some out there
not so much brother so i'm talking to
you as much as i'm talking to our
listeners out there
if you've adopted a kid your kids or
your kids if you've married
into a family and you are co-raising
those kids they are your kids they are
your
kids they are your kids not well that's
my biological kid that's my step kit
nope they're your kids they are worthy
of love they're worthy of being
connected to you hug
them love them hold them accountable
discipline them do all of the things
that you got to do
but all that back to your original
question get with a professional that's
going to walk you through that's going
to gently unveil this to your kid in a
way that he can hear it
that he can digest it he can ask the
questions and more importantly he's
probably not going to have a lot of
questions to ask up front
but he is going to over time ask more
and more questions and you want to set
up an environment
that he leaves that exchange with you
and a counselor he leaves that exchange
knowing
man my dad jonathan is a safe guy for me
to talk to
he loves me he chose me he walked
alongside my mama
when she passed away he's asking me to
help
raise this new baby my little brother
all that you want him super tethered in
as he gets older he's going to feel more
and more untethered
mom's gone who's my real dad you'll walk
through those kind of questions
as the years go on but right now yeah
he's 12 years old you want to begin to
have that conversation asap and do it
with a professional this is not
something you just plop down and be like
well hey i got something to tell you son
you will set off a chain reaction inside
of him that will rage like a like a
california forest fire okay it'll take
years to put out so
uh man i appreciate your heart to all
you parents out there who've got
a young kid that you say that you've
adopted
and you think man it's just gonna stay
between us
um i'm his dad i don't even need to tell
him because i'm always gonna be there
for
man secrets destroy
families secret's to story destroy
families
man you can't kelly can't tell you how
many calls we get how many emails we're
getting about
so i'm 24 and i just did 23 and me and
uh
dot dot dot the gig's up on on those
kind of private things
if you got a kid out of wedlock and you
know that they
are down the street or in the
neighborhood or across the country
and they don't know about you they're
gonna find you they're gonna find you
you gotta have that conversation sooner
rather than later
it's much better coming from you on your
terms
and you getting with the old baby mama
or baby daddy
and figuring out how you're going to do
that because it's not going to stay
secret for long and the longer the
deception the longer the lies go on
the hotter and louder that forest fire
is great question jonathan thank you so
much for joining us
all right so as we wrap up today's show
if you are not i'm just gonna get right
to it if you're not
listening to gary clark jr stop what
you're doing
he is he's not as i was going to say he
is
hendrix reincarnated he is my favorite
guitar player out there right now he's
my favorite singer out right now
he is writing music that just
is smoke as it leaves your speakers man
he's so good
so good i could pick any number of songs
of gary clark jr man
he's out of austin texas the song i
picked here
it's just reminds me of hendrix so much
and it makes my heart glow i don't even
know what i didn't know what heart glow
means like i'm et or something that was
a weird stupid analogy
i gotta put that in the stupid analogy
jar i'm just gonna start finding myself
from this point forward while go out to
eat one day
when we do that all right so this is
from the this land album out in 2019
the song is low down rolling stone
he writes something's going on with me
i'm not who i used to be
no reach the point where darkness
is my compost sound oh my gosh i'm
french
i know i think that's french i hope that
was french i know it's not
what you came here for so fly like an
eagle go be beautiful and free girl
because i'm better off on my own go save
your soul you don't want to go where i
go i'm just a low down rolling stone
barely hanging on
i'm just a low down rolling stone whose
help me ease my mind gary clark
if she doesn't love you i do you're
awesome brother
keep writing great tunes man this has
been the dr john dolone show
you